Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Se dice que la pluma
es más poderosa que la espada
y las autoridades normalmente
están de acuerdo con ello.
Desde folletos religiosos prohibidos
y manifiestos revolucionarios
hasta libros censurados y quemados,
conocemos el potencial de las palabras
para derribar el orden social.
Pero, por extraño que parezca,
hay números que también han sido
prohibidos, por peligrosos.
Nuestros antepasados ​​lejanos marcaban
objetos, usando simples cuñas.
Pero al ir desarrollando la agricultura
y empezar a vivir juntos en grandes grupos
eso ya no fue suficiente.
Conforme los números se hicieron
más complejos,
la gente no solo los usaba,
sino que pensaba en lo que eran,
y cómo funcionaban.
Ya en el 600 a.C., en la antigua Grecia,
los números ya estaban muy desarrollados.
El matemático Pitágoras
y su escuela de seguidores
encontraron patrones numéricos en formas,
en la música y en las estrellas.
Para ellos las matemáticas contenían
los secretos más profundos del universo.
Pero un pitagórico, llamado Hípaso,
descubrió algo perturbador.
Había cantidades, como la diagonal de
un cuadrado, con lados de longitud uno,
que no podían expresarse como combinación
de números enteros o fracciones,
por pequeñas que fueran.
Estos números, a la que
llamamos números irracionales,
se consideraron una amenaza
para la noción pitagórica
de un universo perfecto.
Ellos imaginaban una realidad
que podía describirse
con patrones numéricos racionales.
Los historiadores escriben que Hípaso fue
exiliado por publicar su descubrimiento,
mientras que la leyenda afirma que fue
ahogado como castigo de los dioses.
Mientras que los números irracionales
enfurecieron a los filósofos,
posteriores invenciones matemáticas
también llamaron la atención
de las autoridades políticas y religiosas.
En la Edad Media, mientras Europa
seguía usando los numerales romanos,
otras culturas desarrollaron
sistemas posicionales
que incluían un símbolo para el cero.
Viajeros árabes llevaron ese sistema a
prósperas ciudades marítimas de Italia,
dejando en claro sus ventajas
para mercaderes y banqueros.
Pero las autoridades
fueron más cautelosas.
Los números indoarábigos se consideraban
más fáciles de imitar o cambiar,
sobre todo porque eran menos familiares
para los clientes que para los mercaderes.
El concepto de cero abrió la puerta
a los números negativos
y al registro de deudas,
en una época en que el préstamo de
dinero era mirado con desconfianza.
En el siglo XIII, Florencia prohibió
el uso de los números indoarábigos
para llevar registros.
Y aunque pronto demostraron ser
demasiado útiles para ser ignorados,
las controversias sobre el cero
y los números negativos
continuaron por mucho tiempo.
Los números negativos
se consideraban un absurdo
hasta bien entrado el siglo XIX.
Y matemáticos destacados
como Gerolamo Cardano,
evitaban el uso del cero,
aunque les habría facilitado
encontrar soluciones
para las ecuaciones de tercero
y de cuarto grado.
Incluso hoy es ilegal usar
algunos números, por diversas razones.
Algunos están prohibidos
por lo que representan.
Por ejemplo, hay gobiernos que
prohíben la visualización de números
por tener un significado simbólico,
como la fecha de una revolución
o vínculos a figuras políticas
o partidos de la oposición.
Otras cifras son potencialmente ilegales
debido a la información que contienen.
Prácticamente toda la información,
ya sea en texto,
en imágenes,
en video
o en programas ejecutables, se puede
traducir en una cadena de números.
Pero eso significa
que la información protegida,
sean derechos de autor,
materiales clasificados
o secretos de estado
también puede ser representada
por números.
Por eso, poseer o publicar esos números
puede ser objeto de delito criminal.
Esta idea atrajo la atención en 2001,
cuando un código que se podía usar
para decodificar DVDs
fue compartido y distribuido profusamente
en forma de un gran número primo.
La idea de números ilegales
puede parecer absurda
pero, al igual que las palabras,
los números escritos son una forma
de expresar conceptos e informaciones.
Y en un mundo en el que la informática
y los algoritmos
modelan cada vez más nuestra vida,
el lápiz del matemático
se vuelve cada día más fuerte.